is this a united specific problem I mean
what is it about United computer systems
that makes it so vulnerable to these
glitches because it just happened not so
long ago I don't think it's a united
specific problem as US air and American
put themselves together the CEO focused
a lot on making sure those computer
systems worked well together so maybe
it's the United problem in as much as
they just haven't got these computer
systems to talk as as well together as
they should be at this point in the
merger right I mean and I like the fact
that you bring that up because United
bought continental in that massive deal
of resulting consolidation in the legacy
airline space and one of the big holdups
in a lot of these M&A deals was the fact
that they had to get their computer
systems in sync this is just a natural
fallout from that these are very complex
systems and so I'm I'm actually
surprised to see the mapping problems
this late in the end the process of
putting these two airlines together but
these are very complex systems all right
very complex systems we're also looking
at shares of these Airlines lower today
certainly in line with the overall
market but there are there are a lot of
discussions here George about the
Department of Justice accusing them of
fixing prices yes so a couple things
going on right I think shares are lower
right now or been lowered this year I as
I think investors are trying to figure
out where they go from here right there
the biggest input the biggest cost input
is is fuel prices